so I have a question for the entire cast
with what you know of what's coming what
advice would you personally give your
character for season seven
actually I don't panic boys it is way
too early for that ladies and gentlemen
The Washington Post
no one is I ah be careful with magic
beans with very kohat it why mm-hmm I
wouldn't even duh I don't know how much
you guys know right now only four get
out I know a lot have you guys how many
episodes have you shot so far middle of
the second episode they've only read the
first two scripts so they're really
don't know anything what advice would
you guys give a cactus yeah I read the
script I can tell by the look I just got
I'm going to get in so much trouble
next question that money maybe I would
say to not give up oh that's good mana
that is good we like that right one okay
yes here holy crap I'm back up here hi
guys well I bet hi um I don't know if
your memory back in 2014 was like I do I
do remember um my question is um okay
we're having a nuke like new Cinderella
and like are there going to be other
different versions of Sara cares let's
say an evil queen
Captain Hook or even rebel silk'n but I
love you guys just saw oh I would say
there are going to be new characters we
see but we aren't going to be seeing a
new Rumpelstiltskin hook or what we're
seeing where you're going to see the
same versions of Rumble and the Queen
and hook thing I think I think just to
clear up what we're doing next year is
as you saw Henry's on a new adventure
and Henry is left home and he wants to
go visit other storybrooke's with
different
different stories and different
characters and he obviously falls in
love with Cinderella much like the
romance he had his grandparents had and
what happens is what always happens is
he gets into some trouble and he calls
out for help from his family and the
three people that you see on the stage
that you know and love come to his
rescue so it's really these three and
Henry on an epic adventure and that's
the next chapter once upon a time I
think I think also I believe and the
advice I would give the characters to
give themselves which is also the theme
has never stopped fighting for what you
believe in and never give up
oh I think I think I wanted to just add
to that I have a saying that I always
say I believe you believe they believe
and I think you know this show
challenges your belief system what do
you really do you believe and it
encourages you to believe that there is
something real about fairy tales that
there are happy endings and that things
don't have to end a certain way and you
can just look at things and it's from a
different perspective so it's really
great and I'm really thankful to your
imagination Eddie and Adam for for
challenging us oh thank you I got I got
a question a lot you know are you guys
thank you first of all those are send in
Twitter questions thank you so much
there were two that were very important
to people one and anyone can answer this
is about the Evil Queen or Regina's
infertility if that is going to be
addressed because somebody's spied a
crib in the Evil Queen's happy beginning
she had a crib I saw a crib it was me I
saw a crib wait I can't explain the crib
you see what we want to do I see it
didn't Bobby Elsie the crab wasn't in
your crib however that son that the crib
was in there for Neil no because when
they went over they had to take me on
brought diapers well listen I'm going I
believe y'all believe they believe I'm a
believer in facility Sonya said to
believe I'm gonna believe okay I'll
believe in season seven believe yes even
the next thing is
is also important a lot of people want
to know when there's going to be a
prominent LGBTQ storyline I would say
that we are planning to do it this year
okay those are the two questions you
guys wanted the answer to you got it
let's go to you honey what you got hello
everyone I am a vet my pocket that's an
amazing office that is Austin look at
that oh right your outfit your hood yeah
my name is a hominid Emma but today i'm
home yeah today we're all today your
husband
I made Excalibur and everything so my
question is for Colin I actually met you
yesterday though today would have made a
much better picture how do you feel
about any future Swan Jones children oh
I was going to get there but you got
there before me swine Jones I mean I
think it would be interesting to see I
think
hook and Emma are you know they're they
love each other it's true love and and
they're married so I think the next
logical step for them would be to
consider whether or not we do happen
whether or not they should get like a
dog or oh yeah or you know maybe a cat
or have a baby yeah yeah so what's your
name no the one is Emma your mi in real
life yeah she's called MN real life yeah
yeah you Emma in real life come down
you're Emma come on come on onyomi
misses somebody says cook yeah girl can
you give this to Emma
[Applause]
yeah listen there surprises though
there's a lot of stuff behind this there
surprises - oh mama Oh getting a hug
it's time to it's not can you get up
here are you corsican strapping man the
big song rapping man hi baby girl what's
going on back here please Ginty and I
want to know what your favorite
fairytale I next for everybody I think
is my ovaries I'm sorry
well uh why don't you guys see your
favorite fairy tale a little Gretl for
me hey what happens when you go first
yeah that was mine don't mine I'm never
going to see a Snow White the cinema
when I was five years old
I've always loved up that's my favorite
um The Little Mermaid was the first like
movie I don't mind I love Arielle I just
love a love story I was obsessed with
the sword and stone as a kid absolutely
by far my favorite baby hands Christina
Anderson's Little Mermaid nicely done
nicely done Gabrielle we're going to go
one more down here yes babe honey hi I'm
Ella and I have a very serious question
for Colin um will you marry me
that's what I'd ask going oh which part
of your character hopes you like better
the leather pants or the guy liner I'm
gonna have to go with the guy liner I
think Briana yeah
although the leather pants are nice but
definitely the guy liner thanks Eddie
thank you now that we saw in the new
trailer that there's loads of different
versions of fairytales how do you pick
which versions get put into the show hmm
that is a great question and as we are
on Episode two I would ask you do you
have any ideas you know what for us we
feel like there are certain very much
iconic ones we have told like snowing
charming but differently this show so by
request yeah and I get out so I think
you know what we're going to see you
know there's two people that there's a
few people that couldn't be here today
Makia Cox who is going to be playing
Tiana Tiana and her plane unfortunately
was canceled last night in Chicago due
to storms and she couldn't be here so
Tiana was a natural fit for us because
we felt like we never got to her during
the original sitcom if you stay here for
the rest of the panel you may get a
glimpse yeah you know we are going to
meet Rose Reynolds who is going to be
playing a new version of Alice in
Wonderland since no one watched the
spin-off and you know I'm looking at
because I'm looking at all of you and so
I think that we are looking forward to
meeting new people that we maybe didn't
get to explore as much on Once Upon a
Time and and then go from there
and then we should also mention Adelaide
Kane who couldn't be here today
[Music]
who will be playing one of the wicked
steps she will be playing Rosella and
she is super wicked so we can't wait for
you to see these new people is there um
can various versions of the characters
exists in the same time like I know we
can see Regina and the Evil Queen at the
same time can we see two Cinderella's in
the same realm at the same time well I
think you know the the to Regina's were
based on splitting herself yeah and then
of course we saw a wish realm so I don't
think that when we see
Danya we're going to also run into Jessy
Schram because she's in Storybrooke
married and and I believe she was
teaching a Mommy and Me class yes she's
running a little bit yeah and that's
still going down it's doing well yeah
it's doing really well she's a happy
endings anymore okay yeah I want to
thank you so much for the great
questions on Twitter for your kindness
and care today you guys are our
wonderful fandom I'm so grateful for all
of you and have your way I would love to
thank the fans and the one Christmas
sing for you and thank you our reason
reason that we are
maybe we noticed oh we still have on
he's guilty like the world bestowed we
don't feel like we have new stories to
tell and we feel that is to this fan
down and when you keep showing if you
see this new chapter to see just what
we're doing it's because of you so thank
you thank you guys
[Applause]
you